♪♪
[cash register ding]
[ding]
How much money
do you have on you?
Twenty dollars.
What about you?
Ten.
♪♪
I'm trying to live
my dream.
I am preparing
for three auditions.
Back of the line.
I haven't even gotten
a writing job yet.
I've been taking on
a bunch of freelance jobs.
Hey, squirrel, trying
to buy some lemonade?
♪ Money, money, money ♪
♪ Money makes the world
go 'round ♪
I just need a money order
for ten dollars.
That'll be 20 dollars.
I get a fee
because I have no money.
Yep.
So, you're charging people
for being poor?
Next.
♪ Money, money, money ♪
Those boys really care
about you, don't they?
Yeah, they do.
'Cause you're my friends,
and I love you.
I just don't know if I'm doing
the right thing out here.
I'm just gonna keep working.
Yo, I got the part!
Keep believing.
Just accept me
for who I am.
And we gonna make it.
[screams]
Ah!
I truly believe that.
I can see me now.
- What can you see?
- Me...
in the mirror
across the street.
What up, playboy?!
♪ Money, money, money ♪
♪ Hate it when
you're not around ♪♪